نقلت وكاله بلومبيرج عن مسؤولين امريكيين
قولهم ان القوات الاوكرانيه قد تسعى في
هجومها المرتقب الى قطع الجسر الذي يربط
روسيا بشبه جزيره القرم واضافت الوكاله
نقلا عن مسؤولين مطلعين ان يسعى للتعاقد
مع اربع مئه الف جندي هذا العام معظمهم من
المحاربين القدامى وسكان القرى وبحسب تلك
المصادر فان حمله التعاقد الطموحه ستسمح
بتجنب التجنيد الاجباري مع قرب حمله
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين لعاده انتخابه كما
نقلت الوكاله عن مسؤولين غربيين
واوكرانيين قولهم ان القوات الروسيه التي
تم حجدها في الخريف وتعدادها 300 الف جندي
جميعها موجوده في ساحه المعركه ورغم ذلك
فان تلك القوات لم تتمكن من الاستيلاء على
اي مدينه رئيسيه خلال الاشهر الاخيره
اضافت الوكاله ان الكرملين تراجع عن خطته
لشن هجوم اخر في اوكرانيا هذا الربيع بعد
فشل الاستحواذ على المزيد من الاراضي
وان تركيز القوات الروسيه سينصب على عرقله
الهجوم الاوكراني المتوقع ان يبدا قريبا